jetzt auch motorrad
ich bin bei meinen kisten gefahren hey
leute und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen mod vorstellungen zwar habt ihr ja
genau ihr die da gerade seid euch
gewünscht dass ich mehr so ein bisschen
abgefuckte mods vorstelle so muss wo man
sich einfach denkt also wer den was
insider verstandes verbitten kommentare
woher ich diese stars nehme jedenfalls
wollte ich euch heute mal ein richtig
geilen mord vorstand bzw eine richtig
geile motto ich habe es euch schon hier
schon nötig und zwar ist es dort
beziehen fahrrad mord bzw sein motorrad
mord in minecraft und zwar habe ich ihr
ein motorrad kam das schiff ab dem
moment ich muss eben den donner bisschen
lauter machen kann mich ja dann
draufsetzen diesen sound dieses motors
alter richtig geil ich mache ein
bisschen lauter ist das schön
da kann ich hier fahren und
wie
die kisten gefahren also es ist ein
bisschen wie pferde nur das diesem ort
halten nicht verpackt ist es gibt
bestimmte steuerungsmöglichkeiten
crafting rezept kräfte kräfte und macht
kräfte zu dem kräftigen rezepten komme
ich gleich noch
es gibt bestimmte arten das zu stellen
und zwar wenn ich erstmal gegen ganz
normale blöcke gegen fahrer fährt der
halbhoch 2 block kommt er nicht hoch was
ich denn mal zwei blocks 2 block board
moment da seht da kommt der nicht schon
dann macht er dann bisschen ab und
geräusche ich versuche noch mal ihr euch
zu zeigen da da kommt der schock der
nebendran neben daran vorbei welchem
wasser drin mit auch sehr witzig kommt
ja nicht raus und man kann nachhaltig
mit aufspringen jetzt nicht wehgetan
warten moment vielleicht schaffe ich es
mir noch mal wir zu tun im moment so
vielleicht von hier neben den in der
nähe von hier aber wasser egal wenn man
einmal so ein wasser drin ist kann man
halt normal nicht wieder rauskommen muss
man halt springen damit man wieder
rauskommt und es ist halt hammer geil
ich liebe einfach diesen sound von
motorrädern und was ich liebe das
einfach so richtig voll davon so von von
geländewagen automatik oder so wir haben
ja ich kann ja schlecht mit dem und
nachmachen aber hört ja das ist das sind
halt mehr seine bahnen im gegensatz
irgendwie vw polo oder so die mehr
sondern sorgten diverse nicht also ich
kann echt schlecht geräusch nahmen
jedenfalls fraglich bestimmt so eng wie
geht man da eine medaille als ihr könnt
einfach drauf gehen an dem ihr rechts
klick macht dann wieder drauf und dann
einfach shift und dann seid ihr wieder
darunter ihr könnt auch ihr drücken wenn
ihr darauf sagt das ist halt nicht so
wie beim pferd das er dann beim pferd
habt ihr dann das inventar vom pferd ihr
könnt hier keine sachen drin
es waren das kann
also das sollten sie noch verbessern so
ein bisschen die geräusche ich sitze auf
dem motorrad drauf auf einmal ich hörte
geräusche von so ganz anderen
motorrädern auch noch warte ich hätte
das mal eben deshalb wie ein mob dass
man das töten muss moment still still
still still still man mit mach dein maul
ich möchte es hinaus kann das nicht
ausmachen
und doch doch ich verschenke ich fand
das jetzt einfach hierhin jetzt liegt
bei ihm zurück damit crafting rezepte
zeigen kann aber es ist einfach nur geil
dieses einfach dieses aus prinzip dass
man einfach und dirt bike hat naja
jedenfalls das sind die kräftigen
rezepte crafting rezepte drei eisen in
die oberste reihe dann links in die
mitte und unten im training guckt dann
ein kohl dann habt ihr erst mal den
helden den helm könnt ihr euch nicht
aufsetzen aber den braucht geld um das
so kräften
dann habt ihr hier vier alben ingots
dann in der mitte ein stick dann bekommt
ihr ein riehl davon braucht ihr zwei
stücken bike dieses drahtgestell das
dirt bike frame heißester braucht die
fünf weisen drei oben und zwei so in der
mitte angeordnet
und dann könnt ihr euch halt
verschiedene farben machen und zwei mal
ein blaues das ist ein glattes lazio
hier halt eisendraht gestellt die beiden
räder und den helm und dann einfach das
land wie wenn ihr wollt dass hier aus
gold wenn ihr gold volt und dieses
rezept hier einfach so genau so anstatt
dem lapislazuli könnte dann noch roten
farbstoff neben denen allerdings macht
aus roten blumen also aus rosen und noch
ein grünes was ihr einfach aus grünen
pfad pulver macht was ihr dann mit
kakteen macht und das sind dann halt die
die ich hier halt habe moment so das ist
11 das ist eins und das ist alles
so die kann man halt noch nicht an und
aus machen wir gerade gesehen hab ich
habe eine nachricht bekommen
die kann man nicht ausmachen die scheint
sich auch automatisch an und aber ich
find's einfach geil einfach aus prinzip
so dirt bikes oder so und das ist
einfach weiß ich nicht ich finde es
einfach hammergeil das ist einfach weil
sie nicht bemerkt dass sein kann ich den
verletzten screenshot machen so dass es
schön aussieht
egal nachher so jedenfalls ich habe mir
eine garage aufgebaut jungs ich habe ein
bisschen investiert hier kann ich rein
mein gott was meine ganzen adolf stier
ich hoffe die schweiz jetzt einfach mal
autohöfe okay vielleicht ein doofer name
patrick nennen wir ihn petric schreibt
male betritt das schwein in die
kommentare
nee also locker runter steppen dann
sehen wir eine garage habe ein bisschen
investiert leute ich hab ein bisschen
investiert dann ein paar autos links
hier
ich mache mich hier zum affen
nein ich öfters mal hier beim greenback
schon fliegt damit den beiden becken
kann ich gar nicht schade sei mal so ein
bisschen rum bis fiction hören dann
stemmen uns irgendwo schönach das möchte
ich zu machen so schönen sonnenuntergang
times 20.000 zwischen den
sonnenuntergang
das macht also teil selbst leid
da
so meine lieben freunde ich würde sagen
wenn es euch gefallen hat diese
abgefuckt dem ort wo man eigentlich
nichts zeigen muss sondern einfach nur
basel als sie aus prinzip gibt ich falls
ihr mal zunichte im sonnenuntergang
dann gebt den daumen hoch und schauen
wir 20.000 ex kremlchef ihr könnt mir
auch mods in die kommentare schreiben
wenn ihr oh mein bike strecke könnte
nochmals in die kommentare schreiben
wenn ihr mehr mord videos haben wollt so
eine pro woche oder so dann werde ich
mich da mal dran setzen und dann sehen
wir uns dann beim nächsten mal wieder
ich habe euch alle ganz lieb hatten wir
eine käppi ginge das ist übrigens das
netbook die sätze jetzt immer auf wenn
ich irgendwie watt vorstelle oder sowas
zumindest dieses mal ich werd ich etwas
vergessen aber an alle die zum beispiel
games geguckt haben wissen dass die snap
des todes ist die ist in minecraft
golden nicht wieder viel zu viel wir
sind zunächst mal wieder